Have you ever, uh, have you
ever met Jamie Kilstein?
So Jamie and I have a checkered history.
I don't know if we,
maybe you and I have spoken about
this. I've never met Jamie, but Jamie,
when Jamie was social justice
warrior number one, he went hard.
He went hard on me.
Yeah. Like he, he just,
he just was dunking on me endlessly
in ways that were totally unfair.
I mean, he was just, you know, he was,
he was working very hard
to become an enemy. And,
um, then he had his, his
epiphany, you know, the,
then the social justice mob came for
him over something with almost nothing
right over him trying to get laid.
I mean,
like they were saying he was a
creep or something like that.
Just try hitting on girls. Yeah. I miss
the details there, but then he came then,
so then he's since sent me very,
um,
friendly and apologetic emails about
just, you know, I'm sorry what I did and,
and you know, he, he wants, he wants to do
a podcast. I haven't taken him up on it,
but, um, you know, that, that maybe
that could be an interesting comment.
Sincerely apologetic. Yeah,
he's a good guy. I mean,
he and I had our own issue
at one point in time, um,
over a podcast that we
did versus, uh, it was,
you remember when the Daniel Tosh
rape controversy like, uh, do you,
do you remember this? I know who Tom, I
missed that joke. I should say rape joke.
Um, some woman in a crowd, he was,
he was on stage and he wasn't supposed
to be there. It was at the laugh factory.
And Dom Irrera put them on stage and, uh,
he goes, look, I don't have any material.
What do you guys want to talk about?
And uh, some guy yells out rape.
And uh, that's always helpful. And so he,
you know, it's like some drunk in a crowd.
He goes, Jesus Christ. And so
Daniel Tosh, his take on it. Okay.
What, what's funny about that?
Humiliation. Violence. You know, he's,
he's like berating this guy and trying
to do stand up while he's doing this.
And some woman yells out, actually there's
nothing funny about rape. And he goes,
wouldn't it be funny if someone who just
raped her and everybody starts laughing?
I do remember.
And so this woman wrote a giant blog
about it and she wanted him to apologize
about it and Jamie went after Daniel Tosh
as a con fellow gas as it felt comics
saying that it's, you know, like,
and I was like, well she's a heckler.
The woman heckled, like while he was
trying to do to stand up and he's like,
I don't, I'm not going to support
rape culture. And he's like,
how the fuck is that rape culture?
Like he's,
he's clearly making a joke about
something she said that was very,
very patronizing.
Like obviously he doesn't think there's
something funny about rape. This is,
he's just trying to work
through this ad libs set.
Then he's doing with some guy who yelled
out something that this whole crowd has
to respond to. He can't just ignore
the fact that it happened and go,
how about firetrucks, folks? Why? They
always read, you know, he can't do that.
He's gotta,
he's gotta deal with what this guy said.
And so that's what he tosses out there.
And everybody laughed by the way,
but also isn't the part of his
persona persona just ability.
He takes it to the edge, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So yeah, he's,
yeah, he's edgy comedian.
He's fine. And you know, and Jamie and
I had this little tit for tat about it,
but he,
he's very honest about his mistakes.
Like when you talked to him and he's,
he's got great insight because
he was that guy, you know,
he was that guy that was going back and
forth with people online all day and
checking his mentions like couldn't walk
down the street more than five steps
before he'd pull out his phone and check
has mentioned how people responding to
his latest Dunkin heart take
down or you know, it's just,
it's a toxic thing that people are
doing. It's this, this, you know,
looking for people that are, that are bad
and looking for things that are wrong,
looking for wrong speak.
It's very toxic.
It's toxic for the
people that are doing it.
It's toxic for the people that
are receiving it. It's just,
it's not a way that human beings would
ever communicate in one on one. I mean,
I tried to,
to communicate with people the same way
online as I would if they're right in
front of me. I don't always
succeed, but I try. That's my goal.
My goal is to try to talk to someone
as if they were right in front of me.
That's clearly not how everybody's
handling no. I think road rage as the,
as the best analysis of what's happening
on social media. Yeah. I've adopted that.
I've adopted that way of
looking at it too and,
but the only difference is it road rage.
You know,
there's like a physiological reason
for road rage because you're, you're,
you're in a dangerous situation
that you're subliminally
taking stock going fast.
You're going to have a metal machine with
a bunch of assholes that are probably
looking at their phone and everybody's
going fast and you could die at any
moment if someone goes wrong.
If you're on a highway like the four oh
five when you have five lanes going 70
miles an hour, it is a fucking miracle
that no one dies. And every day we do it.
Every day everything's fine. Yeah. Well,
so let's go back to this idea of what the,
the actual normative response would be
when somebody puts their foot in their
mouth or something from their past gets
disclosed. I mean, the, the, the, the,
the stupid and indefensible thing
they did as a teenager, right? Yeah.
You know, and you know,
like this, you know,
you've got these guys who are now having
their careers destroyed for having
dressed up in black face or in a,
in a,
in a hood for Halloween or whatever
it was. I mean, I, you know, I think,
I think this, that one, um,
politician said he's not even in the,
in the photo,
but the photo was on his yearbook page
or like whatever you put on your yearbook
page in high school, right? Um,
you find out this thing that,
you know, adult is going to defend, right?
But what is the path back? What like
what, like what is the reboot that will,
that should be acceptable because
we don't even know. It seems,
we don't even know what
could conceivably work to
rehabilitate somebody career.
And yet on this other side,
we've got people who again,
are being let out of prison for murders.
Admit they committed,
right? Or rapes, they admit,
admit they committed and they're
rehabilitated. And we, and these are,
these are stories we're supposed
to feel good about, right?
So we have to figure out how to
square this, um, on the left.
And you know, I don't know. I mean, the,
the way I've been thinking about it
is that it has to be intelligible.
How you are different from the person
who committed that thing. Right? Right.
So like if you, if you did
something that was, let's say,
legit racist when you
were 20 and like mark,
Mark Wahlberg as an example of this
[inaudible] he was running around just
beating people senseless. Right.
And for avowed racist motives.
I believe when he was a teenager, he
would got lost his eye. Right? Yeah.
I mean it's less. Yeah. So,
but, and I think that was a,
I think I was a Vietnamese guy.
He attacked or uh, but, um,
he was just doing truly indefensible
things. Now I don't know what sort of,
you know, PR moment he has had since
or how he's apologized for it or,
but I mean, that was a, that was a
very different time. I think if it was,
if all of that stuff was
being discovered about him,
now there may be no way back
is with this day and age,
it could be reignited.
Right.
Like even though he's apologized for it
and even though that it's been addressed,
it absolutely get reignited.
Just me talking about it on your podcast
is fucking him over. Right. Good. Yeah.
I mean, and also people have to recognize
that there's some things you can't
retroactively instill today's ideas of
what constitutes racism on 1985 so if you
were in high school in 1985 and you
dressed up as Mr t, right? That you know,
I don't know if that was racist back then.
I never did it,
but I don't know if that's racist.
Like if you had a bunch of gold chains
and you made your hair black and are you
making you made your face black
and gave herself a Mohawk? He said,
I'm Mr t for Halloween and
the pictures emerged today.
What you did when you went door to door
when you were 15 or 12 or whatever,
you were knocking on people's doors
and everybody was laughing. Oh,
you're mister T. Nobody thought it
was racist, but today let's take that.
Let's take the hard case. Let's
say you were racist, right? I mean,
so like I had this Guy Christian Pitch
Julinia on my podcast once who's at x,
Neo Nazi, they just legit racist, right?
He's got all the tattoos to prove it.
And now their major problems with
Christian pitcher Laney as, as,
as I think you know, uh, that I
discovered after that podcast. But, um,
so this is not an endorsement of
him, sorry Christian. But the, the,
the, there is a path back. I mean, so
like he is celebrated on the left. Yeah.
He's a former Neo Nazi
and he's, you know, I, I,
I discovered him on Sarah
Silvermans show on wherever that is,
Hulu. Um, and, uh, you know,
he's a darling of the left,
right.
And Darlene of Msnbc for
this redemption story. So,
but what is the,
you take someone,
any of these politicians who have
something in their backstory that is ugly.
Uh,
my feeling is all there has to be,
is a transparent and intelligible account
of how you are now different of how
you can actually honestly look
back on this thing and say, yeah,
I am as embarrassed by that as you think
I should be. Right. That's not like,
that is nothing that, that does not
represent how I view the world at all now.
Uh,
but there's just,
there's a s the spirit of the
time on social media, again,
especially on the left and to our total
dysfunction politically is to never
accept any of that. I mean, there's,
there is no apology good enough. And,
um, or the, or there's, you know,
the most cynical possible interpretation
of your, uh, of your apology.
It's like you're just trying to, you're
the only reason why you're apologizing.
It's because you want to
save your job. Right. Um,
and that we have to figure out how to,
I mean, we just need some, you know,
recovery disk that we can reboot
from here because it's just not, uh,
it's, this is going someplace
terrible. And again,
to look at it through the Lens
narrowly politically of, uh, you know,
over the next two years, it's, it's to
the massive disadvantage of the left.
It certainly is,
but I don't see any way to fix that.
Like with the current climate and
this current attitude where people are
engaging in this recreational outrage,
it fits the climate. I don't mean,
I don't know what would have to happen
for people to come to some sort of a
realization. I mean, it would have to
happen to them like it did to James.
Like what happened with Jamie Kilstein
is it, they turned on him and he's like,
oh my God, this is awful. Like
I'm [inaudible] [inaudible].
And then he realized,
you know, I mean, I don't know what
other thing could happen. Well, I mean,
what weird, the game we're
playing is part of it. I mean,
you and I are in a position
to take risks that, you know,
even the people at the top of
journalism can't. I mean like, yeah,
like Megan Kelly says one
wrong thing and you know,
it doesn't matter that she's got a $20
million contract, she's just, she's fired.
Uh, and when you look at the thing that
she said, I mean, it was just a question.
Yeah. She, I mean,
she just didn't seem to understand how
charged the phrase black face was. Right.
She's just ignorant of that piece of
history or something. But like, you know,
so she just, she should, she
put her foot in her mouth.
She gave an apology that was just like,
you know, full blown hostage video.
Apologies. Just like, you know,
just like I am so fucking sorry.
You don't even know.
Like,
here take a sample of my blood
and you'll just see my test,
my cortisol and not good enough,
not good enough.
And they let her say the apology
till he is even more crazy.
They let her come back, say the apology
and then go good. Thanks for doing that.
Yeah. So, but so she,
no one's job in that space is secure
enough where they can take real risks,
but you know, you and I, you know,
you and I could do an interview
with Louis C K right? Like,
and just process his,
coming back into standups and do it
in a way where people didn't like it.
You just say, okay, fuck off. Right.
This is the conversation we had.
And I think modeling that more
and more. I mean, I think,
I think we have to take those risks and
people like us have to take those risks
and hope to break the spell by
having those conversations in public.